each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's actually my pleasure to introduce
David for this morning for the keynote
and so David's going to give us the
keynote today on biology a move to dry
labs and so please welcome David 24 this
morning thank you Dan it's a pleasure to
be here thanks the organizers for
inviting me the title of my talk is
biology from what to dry for those of
you that know me you know I've been
working in biology for the last 10 years
now and you may also know that I move my
group from Seattle to Los Angeles a few
years back and that's not what this talk
is about rather it's about an evolution
that's going on in the field of biology
within the fourth paradigm I'm sure
you're all familiar with the fourth
paradigm this is a slide from one of Jim
Gray's last talks where he introduces
the fourth paradigm it's about data
intensive science and what I've noticed
over the last two decades is that
biology has changed dramatically twice
the first change I saw was biology going
from these creative one-off experiments
usually with small amounts of data to a
situation where there was lots of data
so this would be the move into the
fourth paradigm so in the old days at
least when I was going to school biology
was about somebody falling asleep in
front of a fire and seeing a snake come
out of the fire and bite its tail and go
oh I discovered the I figured out what
benzene is you've probably all heard
that story but within the last 20 years
or so we now can easily measure DNA RNA
protein
is the basic building blocks of biology
we can do so in all sorts of different
experimental circumstances gather lots
of data and it becomes much much easier
to discover things and as a data analyst
someone goes machine learning statistics
it's been very good for us the data is
large the scientists occasionally give
us these wonderful bits of data kind of
like in The Hunger Games where the guys
throwing out the bread and we all grab
it and so this is wonderful and we
analyze it we give it back to the
scientist and we make we make good
progress but there's another change
that's happening much more recently
within the last few years I've been able
to experience it directly and I've seen
lots of others who are experienced
experiencing this change as well and
that is because there's so much data out
there you actually don't need
collaborators to do the science directly
there's there's all sorts of data
available where you as a analyst and of
course you have to learn some biology as
well can come in look at look at a
situation decide I would be interesting
to test this hypothesis and the data is
already there available to you to do
that testing so you can without any
collaboration with a wet lab at all you
can write scientific papers so what I
like to do today is give you a couple of
examples in this category and you'll see
how within those examples we're kind of
transitioning into this category and
then I'll give you a few examples where
we've done some work directly without
any collaboration and have been able to
publish some real science the work that
you're going to hear about involves
these folks these are the researchers in
the e science research group great gang
okay so let's start with the genomics
revolution we'll talk about a project in
this space I'm sure you all know there
is a genomics revolution going on now
and what's driving that revolution is
the cost of sequencing DNA is decreasing
and it's decreasing even more rapidly
then Moore's Law so this graph here is a
plot of how much it costs to single a
single human genome as a function of
time this white line here represents
Moore's law scaled and you can see the
costs are just dropping dramatically
over a little over a decade go it costs
a hundred million dollars to sequence
the first human genome and any day now
we're going to hear from the XPrize
folks that someone is going to sequence
human genome for a thousand dollars per
person and besides the human genome you
can measure a million genetic markers
now for well under one hundred dollars a
person so with that decrease in cost
comes a wealth of data and one of the
things you can do with that data is
personalized medicine you can identify
genetic markers that correlate with
things that are clinical interest such
as are you likely to get a disease will
you react badly to a drug will you react
favorably to a drug and then for each
individual you once you know you all
have to know their whole genome you just
know say a million genetic markers from
them for this cost of a hundred dollars
and you're able to personalize the
treatment that you give these
individuals now one common way for
finding these associations between
genetic markers and traits of interest
is called jiwa which stands for
genome-wide Association studies what you
do it's very simple you think of
something that's interesting to you some
trade of interest coronary artery
coronary artery disease status age of
death does this drug work or not and you
get a bunch of people for which let's
say the drug works and a bunch of people
for which the drug doesn't work maybe a
thousand people each you sequence their
genome or get measure a million genetic
markers sometimes called snips for
single nucleotide polymorphisms you
measure these snips and then you just
look for differences across these
million markers between the people and
one group and the people and the other
group it's very straightforward it's the
has been done now for almost five five
to ten years and what you see here is
are some of the results from that each
one of these bars is one of your
chromosomes chromosome one chromosome to
chromosome 3 and each of these colored
dots corresponds to some study that's
found a correlation between this region
of the chromosome and some trade of
interest you can see there's a lot of
them this is actually an old slide now
these findings are growing exponentially
and if you listen to the radio while
you're driving around you probably ever
at least once a week you hear the result
of a new study where they found some
association between your genetics and
some interesting trait here's an example
of G wasps in action we did this with
Brian Trainor at the NIH he had a cohort
of individuals from Finland about 500 of
whom had Lou Gehrig's disease or ALS and
the other 500 were normal we did the G
wasps we found a few genetic markers
that were highly associated with the
differences in these two groups and
after a bit after rather a lot of work
on Brian's part the snips are spaced
across the genome so once you find an
associated snip you have to actually
have to then look for the actual causal
region of the DNA which is usually near
the snip that does does the that that's
actually directly responsible for the
disease but he did that in the lab and
he was able to find this DNA change and
it turned out to be a single DNA change
that accounted for this cohort and in
fact when he looked further it accounted
for a third of all inherited Lou
Gehrig's disease in Europe so this is
this was a very large finding published
in neuron last year but the point is
it's straightforward to do and you do in
our case you needed a collaborator he
had to collect the individuals to do the
study and then he had to go back into
to lab to isolate the the actual cause
of the of the disease okay so there are
several issues with G us one is that
this has been going on now for a well
and so a lot of the hanging fruit has
been picked much of the remaining signal
is weak and scattered across the genome
and so to pick up these remaining
signals we need lots of data and people
have recognized this in various groups
are collecting large amounts of data
decode the team that basically is
sequenced everyone in Iceland 23andme
you may have heard about Kaiser
Permanente they all now have genomes for
over a hundred thousand people and are
doing this gos work but there's an issue
when you collect lots of data for lots
of people you get what's called
confounding so you get your data you run
your simple statistical analyses looking
for these differences between groups and
you find a significant difference but it
turns out that that that association is
false it's not a has nothing to do with
a causal effect of the snips on the
trait and the reason is because the this
data gets complicated when it gets large
usually have multiple ethnicities you
have closely related individuals in that
data and that causes this confounding
and let me give you an example of that
so let's consider just one genetic
marker one snip it has two values a or t
remember it's actg usually at any given
snip you only see two so let's say we
have a and T and each circle here
represents a person and the the genetic
marker that they have so this column
here are the cases these are the people
that have the disease and these the
controls these are the people that don't
have the disease and if you look naively
you say oh there's more a's in the cases
and there's more T's in the controls so
i found an association but it turns out
this association is false due to
confounding and what's really going on
is there there's actually two
populations of people that you've
measured a population one show
here in population to shown here maybe
it's different ethnicities so in
population one there's mores than T's
and in population to there's more T's
than a's and then finally it just
happens by the way you gathered your
data that there's more of population one
in cases and more of population two and
the controls these things taking
together makes it look like there's an
association between having the snip and
having the disease but it's a false one
okay so we want to get rid of this
problem and there are actually
statistical algorithms out there to do
that the animal breeders people have
been looking at genetics of animals for
a long long time hundred years the human
stuff is very recent but the animal
breeders because of this they have their
act together they developed beautiful
statistical algorithms for handling this
problem and they're called linear mixed
models they work great but there's one
catch they're very computationally
expensive so if you analyze n
individuals with a linear mixed model it
will cost you o n cubed runtime and oh n
squared memory use to do so so if you
get data sets with over 5,000 people in
it the memory use alone is going to
start to kill you and you're going to
have to wait a long long time to get an
answer but what we did at Microsoft in
my group is basically with algebra and
we figured out how to reduce this
runtime and memory used to linear and to
do so it was a lot of algebra and
there's one statistical trick that we
used and it turned out that this
statistical trick not only made the
analysis faster but it made it more
accurate so we were actually able to see
more signal by doing this trick then
then not so this is one of those very
rare circumstances in computer science
where you do something to make an
algorithm faster or use less memory and
you improve that algorithm at the same
time so we got very lucky here we
published these results in nature
in two different articles and it's being
used quite a bit right now okay let me
let me stop there any questions I'm
going to move on to another project okay
now maybe you'll think of something as
we go okay this is another project I've
been working on for almost ten years
having to do with the design of vaccines
for HIV and before I was working in
biology at Microsoft I was working on
various machine learning projects and
one thing I did was build a spam filter
this was way back in nineteen
ninety-seven I guess I have a very low
tolerance for junk mail because after I
received my tenth or so junk mail I said
this is it I've had it I do not want to
ever see one of these things again and I
told my team start gathering your your
junk mail and your regular mail we're
going to build a machine learning filter
to distinguish the two we did and
eventually that machine learning filter
got shipped in all sorts of different
products at Microsoft Outlook hotmail
exchange and so forth and once we
started deploying this thing in the real
world the spammers took notice as you
might know already and they started
changing their messages to get around
our filters so we would catch the word
viagra and I say oh we'll just put it
will change one of the A's to an @ sign
and will fool this spam filter it will
miss the word and so it won't be able to
detect this message as being spam and we
said ah they've changed their a to an @
sign okay well we'll recognize that and
then the spammers would say Oh they've
figured that one out let's put a bitmap
in that says viagra so they'll never see
that and then we say okay we'll put in a
we'll put in a recognition system that
looks at bitmaps and actually tries to
read them and this goes back this went
back and forth and back and forth over a
couple of years and it won't at some
point we said you know this has got to
stop
what can we do and we said well let's go
after the weak link of these spammers
and one of the at least one of their
weak links is they have to get money
from you somehow so we started
cataloging the links in email messages
that take you away to some spot to get
your credit card number or something
like that and that worked very well so
we had this catalog of junk mail links
or links to take you to sites to extract
money from you and so if a message had
one of those links in it we think it's
very likely to be junk mail and we would
flag it that worked great so going after
the weak link of the spammers turned out
to be a good solution ok so now
fast-forward five or ten years i'm
looking at HIV and situations actually
pretty similar HIV is a virus and it's a
it's a rather odd virus because it
mutates so rapidly if you look at how
much HIV mutates when it gets into a
single individual so usually it will
come into an individual in exactly one
form one strain and then you look a
couple years later you see as much
evolution taking place as you do if you
looked at the entire evolution of
influenza and known history so that's
how bad HIV is it really really mutates
so what do we do so we tried several
things but then there's this connection
with the spam filtering which is HIV
your immune system starts to attack HIV
HIV mutates to avoid that attack then
your immune system re attacks and you go
back and forth very similar situation as
in the spam filtering case so we thought
huh is there a weak link of HIV and for
the last five years or so now we've been
we've been doing some research based on
this hypothesis that there are weak
links in HIV and I think we now have
evidence that there are so let me go
through that this is a schematic of HIV
HIV is about 9,000 nucleotides long it
codes for a series of protein
as shown here gag pole viv envelope and
so forth and our working hypothesis is
that among these 9000 nucleotides are
small regions which I've denoted here in
red there might be more of them
hopefully there are more of them small
regions tiny regions where if HIV is
forced to mutate in these regions due to
an attack by your immune system HIV will
become weak or ideally dead and then the
vast majority of regions in HIV we think
are fine your immune system tax they are
nothing happens it mutates HIV mutates
to avoid the attack and it's fine and
that's what's shown here what we think
is going on is left to its own devices
our immune system attacks at random
spots along HIV missing these vulnerable
spots and so HIV unfortunately lives
lives on happily inside your system ok
so what we want to do then is obviously
identify these weak points and then
design a vaccine that teaches your
immune system to attack at precisely
those weak points ok so now you get the
vaccine this is before you have HIV you
get the vaccine your immune system
already knows where the weak spots are
and then if you are unfortunate enough
to get infected with HIV your immune
system directs the attack precisely
where it should be at these vulnerable
spots on HIV either weakening or killing
the virus so that's that's the working
hypothesis we've been now studying this
for as I said about five years with
Bruce Walker at Harvard using various
experiments we have identified maybe a
half-dozen weak spots which is very
encouraging but it's not enough the
reason it's not enough is because we all
have different immune systems just like
we have different blood types you know
type a Type B typo we have different
immune system types in fact there's a
lot of different types hundreds of
different types across the human race
and different types of immune systems
can attack are only able to
at different spots along HIV so even
those let's say this is a vulnerable
point here if you have a particular
immune system you know you might not be
able to attack there so what we want to
do is catalog enough vulnerable points
such that each immune system type or at
least most immune system types are
capable of attacking at least one of
these vulnerable spots and then we'll
give a cocktail vaccine that teaches
different immune systems different
places to attack along HIV so we're
continuing to do this work but one line
of work is instead of looking at single
points of attack let's look at double
points of attack and to illustrate that
I want to switch to a demo here this is
a tool that we built that's helped our
researchers or collaborators find two
points of attack let's see okay right
there see this is a kind of bluish and
this is rather pinkish these are this is
a molecule of HIV folded in its
functional form and you see here two
points along HIV they're not near each
other in linear space but they're near
each other in physical space and these
two points come very close to each other
and they probably influence one another
that is if this site were to mutate then
this site probably needs to mutate as
well to maintain the function of this
molecule all right and so this is a
possible to point attack on HIV what we
can do is make a vaccine that tells the
immune system to attack at the pink spot
forcing HIV to mutate here but also
telling the immune system to attack the
amino acid that this amino acid would
become if it were forced to mutate
because this one mutates okay so we want
to put the virus between a rock and a
hard place we want to force it to either
mutate here in which case it'll die or
well mutate here and not mutate here
that's that's the basic idea
so we force it to mutate here and not
mutate here then it has it can either
not mutate at all in which case it'll
die or it can mutate and therefore hurt
the function of the protein because this
one won't be able to mutate this one
mutates messes up the function of the
protein so to do that we're using a
completely a wet/dry lab approach this
is now kind of the move into the dry lab
where we're taking publicly available
data which basically is data from
individuals about their sequences that
they have in them and what their immune
system type is and we're able to look
for these places in HIV where when one
amino acid mutates another one mutates
as well this program is called file OD
this is meant to be a linear
representation of the gag protein now
stretched out not folded anymore and all
these lines here show places of
covariation so when the amino acid here
mutates the amino acid over here mutates
the amino acid over here mutates and so
forth so this gives us a look into the
virus in its constraints what how it how
these pairs of amino acids evolve and
therefore potential to point positions
for for attack okay so again that that's
varied so we've moved from the wet lab
collaborating with Bruce Walker now into
the dry lab looking for these two point
positions of attack just with data
that's that's available okay any
questions about that and move to with
some real real dry lab projects now all
right so one thing that's happening in
biology is that not only is data a
commodity now we know the basic building
blocks RNA DNA protein we can measure
those very easily but it's so
commonplace now that there
our sites that are commercial companies
that are starting that lets you just
order these experiments online so you
can go online and say I want this strain
of mouse give give half of them this
drug given half of them this other drug
measure their gene expression and mail
back the data to me and you never have
to touch a wet lab so there's it's it's
data for order but as I was saying at
the beginning of the talk there's
already a lot of data out there this is
part of the fourth paradigm and so let
me show you some examples of what you
can do with data that's already out
there basic science okay so I think
you've all had at least one biology
class and in that biology class you were
inevitably told about the two theories
of evolution Lamarque's theory and
Darwin's theory and you know Darwin had
this idea there's something in you that
gets passed down and causes your traits
and Lamarck had this absolutely crazy
theory that said things that happen to
you during your life would influence
something inside of you that got passed
down and then change your traits and the
canonical example was the giraffe who
whose neck grows ever longer because
it's trying to reach for those higher
bits of food and then the longer neck
somehow gets passed down into its
generations and the neck just keeps
getting longer and longer and I remember
my biology teacher just laughing you
know saying oh isn't this a silly theory
you know Darwin's theory is obviously
correct and now a few years ago we
realized that both these theories are
correct there's the genome which is what
Darwin was talking about and there's the
epigenome which is what Lamarque is
talking about and the idea here is that
things that happen to you during your
lifetime usually traumatic events change
this thing called the epigenome which
then gets passed down to your offspring
just like your DNA and so this epigenome
now is becoming better better
characterized but one thing we were
interested in was is their relationship
between the genome and the epigenome
your genome influences what you look
like fat you are you know how long
you're going to live and so forth maybe
it influences what happens to your
epigenome and there's there was data out
there that allowed us to look at this
question it was online it's a DB gap a
system you can go you can go in and with
a little bit of you have to wait a
couple weeks or months to get permission
to use it but once you have that
permission you get the data and you
analyze it and we analyze that data this
is a project with Jennifer list garden
and others at in my group and sure
enough we found very distinct
interactions between the genome and
epigenome and this paper is has been
accepted for publication nope no outside
collaboration okay here's here's one of
my favorite examples this is from the
Butte lab at Stanford published in
science last year there's this thing
called drug repurposing so the idea is a
drug company will develop a drug for a
specific purpose and it'll cost lots and
lots of money to get it through the FDA
safety approvals or safety trials
efficacy trials and eventually gets used
but then occasionally it's discovered
usually by happenstance that the drug is
useful for something else minoxidil is a
good example it's it was a drug design
for lowering your blood pressure and
people who were receiving this drug got
unwanted hair all over the place and
some clever person said wait a minute
hair is not necessarily unwanted and
figured out that if you pour this stuff
on your head you can grow hair back on
your head so on the top of your head so
it became a very good drug for that
purpose I think it's probably used a lot
more for that purpose than it was for
its original purpose now so this is drug
repurposing and these folks is Stan for
thought huh wonder if we could use
available data to more deliberately
repurpose drugs than just wait around
for some interesting
coincidence to be observed so they did
something very simple there's data out
there relating disease and gene
expression so you have maybe 20,000
different genes and there's data they're
saying if there's differences in how
this particular gene is expressed
whether you have a disease or not so
this this matrix or this array here is
meant to represent these differences
between whether there's an expression or
not for each gene so that each one of
these squares represents a gene and
let's say green represents no difference
in red represents a lot of difference
and white is neutral okay so you have
that data publicly available there's
also a similar data that's publicly
available relating drugs to gene
expression so you this box means this
particular a particular gene is
expressed very differently if you take
the drug versus if you don't take the
drug and so you have a profile like that
across all 20,000 genes and so these
folks at Stanford hypothesized well if
you have two profiles that are
anti-correlated if you have a disease
profile and a drug profile that are
anti-correlated maybe taking that drug
will help with the disease so right so
if a gene goes up when you take a drug
and it goes down when you have a disease
maybe there's something there to it
especially if you look across all genes
so they did that they found some
correlations they found one very strong
correlation which is between drug use
for treating ulcers called cimetidine
and the disease adenocarcinoma of the
lung and sure enough they tried it out
it works so again no except for the
final trial obviously you have to go
back and try it but they found this drug
with just data off the shelf okay and
finally one last project going back to
the G was-- work that I mentioned at the
beginning of my talk this is what we
call the Moondog project at Microsoft
there is data publicly available again
from the Wellcome Trust in England on
data for seven common diseases so for
individuals with these seven diseases
and four set of controls they measured
about a half a million snips the
diseases include their very common type
1 diabetes type 2 diabetes coronary
artery disease hypertension and so on so
people have analyzed this data a lot but
we had fast limb available to us now
which allows us to analyze this very
large data set very quickly and we have
a jour which is a system that allows you
to do parallel computation very easily
this is actually commercially available
anybody can use it and so we thought
well let's let's go for the next big
problem which is to look at not how
single snips interact with these traits
which are whether you get these diseases
or not but how pairs of snips interact
with these traits so we want to look at
interactions either between steps within
the same gene or snips and different
genes all of them there's 60 billion
pairs to look at so without fast limb
and without a sure we wouldn't have been
able to do this but we had it so we did
it this 400 compute years worth of work
we did it in less than a day thanks to a
juror and sure enough we found some very
interesting interactions in these snips
for coronary for one of the diseases
namely coronary artery disease and this
paper is now in submission as well okay
so I just want to take you through this
tour of what's happening in biology it
seems it's not just me in my group
there's lots of groups throughout the
country now that are producing very very
legitimate biology work without the need
for collaboration and again this is I
think one of the natural steps that
we're going to see within the fourth
paradigm with that I'll take questions
questions
it's a very interesting talk I just have
a question regarding how you validate
the soy lab experiments back to the wet
lab or the real problems after you did
the Easons design how could you
recommend are you totally driving all
the wet lab thank you well you'll have a
wet lab when you want to deploy it you
know if you're if you discover a drug in
the repurposing case you discover these
associations which will lead possibly to
discovery of drug you have to bring the
clinical side at least the clinical side
back in which could involve a wet lab
but validation is a very good point
there's so much data out there and
analysis of the data that's been done
when you find a new Association you can
check the literature where these
datasets and see whether the with a
different analysis and with a different
cohort of people you find the same
Association so you can either look in
the literature might already be there
unvalidated and now you have a
validation for it or you can go into
another data set because there are so
there is so much data out there on a
different set of people do the same
experiment again and see if it checks
yes
for free well I guess either for free or
for a call you know a reasonable cost
sure the eye you can go on as you're
down and get out your credit card and
you have those computational resources
available to you some of the the
methylation experiment for example was
done on a single machine so it depends
on what question you're asking we
deliberately that that last slide I
showed you with the Moondog project we
deliberately went after something that
was computationally difficult just to
show the world now we're where we are
and that we can actually take the next
step but there's a lot of questions you
can answer on a single machine with good
algorithms yeah I was wondering though
if places that are making the data
available or also starting to make
compute available oh the same places and
well people are making data available
are people like the DB gap and the
European corresponding organization his
name slips my mind right now but they
are not making the computation available
but it's you can download it and then
you can download the data and then move
it to some site where you where the
computation is available yeah it seems
not convene it's much better to move the
computation right data in these cases
and no one's figured that no one's
figured people have figured that out but
they haven't figured out how to make it
work yet you know thank you for the nice
talk um I'm wondering how those
algorithm you present today or other
viral bioinformatics algorithm general
computationally intensive I'm so my
question is I guess my question is so
compared with the hpc computing
environment or cloud computing so those
arguments are enough to learn in cloud
environments or if you use HPC machines
then can you get more faster wizard
something like that so is your question
are the algorithms fast enough that you
don't need a cloud fast enough to use
the clouds or can you do more faster
kappa faster resort if you use hpc the
big issue there is the size of the data
so if your if your data is huge getting
it to the cloud is the bottleneck and
there are plenty examples on both sides
there's there's a cancer genomics data
set that they're putting together at
UCSC 10 petabytes you're not going to
move that to the cloud you're going to
move your computation to to that data
but there's plenty of other there's
smallish data sets on DB gap where for
example that with the methylation with
the epigenetic question that we looked
at was simple enough to download and run
on a single machine so there's both
extremes happening great thank you yeah
so do you see the major data centers
making of effort to start putting data
at large data sets on the cloud yeah I
know there was the thousand Genome
Project dead but ever is actually
remarkably small number that actually
keep the up-to-date data sets in the
cloud for this very reason yes I know
there's a desire to do that and that the
reality has not caught up with that
desire yet but there's a lot of people
thinking about that and I expect so long
as the the payoffs from these genetic
analyses that are very large right now
if as if they continue I think we'll see
it happening maybe just along those
lines is the is the bottom line tend to
be the data providers or the cloud
providers because one of the tricks with
the thousand genomes project wizard
amazon hosted it for free and i think
one of the major bottlenecks will be
security and privacy i think that's the
biggest bottleneck because the thousand
genomes project is completely open
that's that
an exception sorry just most of the data
sets you mentioned where they mentioned
publicly available were they still
encumbered with privacy concerns or
absolutely IC so everything you talked
about was not something I can just go
download myself I think a thousand
genomes is the one exception and Hannah
hapmap you can just go and download but
most of the data its genetic data it's
identified you can identify human being
with that data and so there's there's I
would say well less than half the data
you can download without IRB approval
and most of the data you need IRB
approval to to download which takes
months if ever gone just want to see
final question so most of the projects
you talked about you went through a
process of getting IRB approval for the
publicly available data as our people
were you able to do the work let's see
the ones I talked about the Wellcome
Trust data you do not need I RB but it
took two months to get the data because
they check you out first and make sure
your legitimate the dbgap did is the
same took about two months yeah so we
these projects sort of rent it's just a
random coincidence that leads to happen
not to involve IRB approval but we do
have IRB approval and we're doing many
more projects with much more data
available after you get IRB approval
so the last part of your talk was
concerned with finding new new drugs or
new applications for drugs I wonder if
you could use the methods there in
reverse and if you could use this kind
of scanning to eliminate medications
that are not effective as you know as
they are sold or to counter you know the
reports you sometimes read that
pharmaceutical companies are inventing
diseases rather than drugs to keep
reselling rebranding drugs that they
have actually mental disorders or could
you launch a counter-attack using your
methods you could certainly do that scan
and see and check that I think usually
the case is if a drug has been approved
by the FDA for given purpose it probably
helps at least some people for that
purpose it would be tough for something
otherwise to happen however what we're
seeing in the pharmacogenetic space is
that a drug that works for one person
does not necessarily work for another
person and so looking for correlations
between your genome and whether a drug
works for you is a very useful endeavor
and there's lots and lots of people
doing that and I expect very soon to see
a situation where you go into your
pharmacy and you probably know right now
if you hand a pharmacist a prescription
they will check that prescription
against any other prescriptions they've
they've given you for drug drug
interactions I suspect will very soon
see the same thing happening with drug
genome interactions and if there is an
interaction they'll get on the phone
with your doc and state you know this
drug is either going to really high on
this patient or it's not going to work
for them let's think of something else
we can give them um is your data skewed
by essentially people publishing just
the positive data not the negative stuff
so essentially what you said about is
essentially able to do experiments and
the dried up but essentially you can't
do those experiments you can't do them
properly if I validating every single
one of them in the wet lab as well so
you don't really remove the actual need
to do the experiment properly
there there's so much there is a lot of
data out there that fits the description
you describe it but fortunately there's
a lot of meta information usually a
paper or to describing the work around
the generation of that data and you can
see whether there's going to be biases
in the way the data is collected I would
say the majority for example on dbgap
there's a lot of g wass data there and
because it's g was data it was
deliberately collected to have not only
cases but controls people that don't
have the disease kind of randomly
selected and again there's articles
describing the collection of that work
and you can read those articles and
there's details about how that data was
collected and you can decide whether
that day is appropriate for a particular
analysis that you want to do so it's
actually a fairly there's we're in a
fairly good situation yes there's bias
data there but it's labeled as such and
you can and you can know to avoid it I'm
following on I used to work for one of
the resources where I guess you're
getting some of your data from for the
gene expression and stuff and
essentially the problem without
resources that essentially it's putting
up the factory values and so it's not so
if you use a certain experiment for
instance for a drug as a draw at
objector compound and protector and the
vigil over a certain time point so it's
it's a compound factor it's not just one
so how does your resort state of pulling
out that data or I'm starting right that
data after well essentially the data is
coming right back to you yeah is
essentially not correct because it's
giving you a p-value for instance which
is based on actual data store itself so
everything is we normalized all not take
the data set do you do extra validation
on that yeah well one thing you can do I
can't tell you the answer for the the
drug repurposing study in particular
because that's not my work that was done
by a tool bute at Stanford so I'm not
sure exactly what he did to adjust for
those issues he may have done nothing
and he was simply looked for he lived
with the confounding and found a result
that happened to work perhaps not
justifiable
so through the statistics but he's a
good statistician so I suspect that he
did whatever he could given the data he
had to avoid those things it for example
it might be batch effects and if in this
data he may have thrown out any data
that didn't have the batch labelings on
them and then using statistical methods
to adjust for those batch effects but
again I can't tell you what he did
exactly because it is it's his study any
other john and david so one of the
things you're kind of coming out of the
answers is it you still have to do your
due diligence on the data sets and the
information using it's not just going
out and pulling down willy nilly data
sets and using them that's correct so my
question is just about what what might
happen in the future so if you imagine
10 years down the down the track what
what would that look like you know and
what do we need to what are the key
things we need to do to get there to
make us more efficient and productive
yeah well there's so many things we can
do right now I feel like yeah Alan
Turing being asked right after he
developed his theory to predict Twitter
and Facebook there's a there's a lot of
when you have this exponential growth or
decrease in the cost of DNA it's kind of
hard to predict all the wonderful things
that are going to happen some things
that will definitely happen our
personalized medicine so let me focus on
that one personalized medicine has
already begun in many locations at UCLA
right now if you walk into a into the
hospital with some condition if the
doctor thinks that there might be some
insights from your genome to help
diagnose or treat that condition he can
write a prescription if you will for a
genetic test that gets done on the spot
and within 24 hours he's got the results
back to help guide diagnosis and
treatment for you I think that's going
to be in ten years that's going to be
commonplace how do we get there more
quickly
we're going to need continual
improvement in computation and algorithm
algorithm design and we're going to need
a lot of thinking about the ethics and
privacy around this data that's probably
I think that's going to be the biggest
bottleneck to getting to the place that
I just described any other questions
well let's thank David again for talk